hi i'm derek downey a developer advocate
for google cloud
i am excited to share some great news if
you are using cloud spanner and have
downstream systems that need to be aware
of data changes in near real time
getting data changes from one system
into another especially in real time can
be challenging
to address this cloud spanner just
released change streams to make it easy
to set up pipelines to process changes
made to your spanner data
in this video i will explain what chain
streams are and what is required to set
them up
then i will show you how easy it is to
set up a change stream and a pipeline to
process changes made to your spanner
data into a downstream bigquery
analytics environment
finally i'll go over some typical use
cases for change streams and how spanner
makes it easy to enable those use cases
[Music]
so what are change streams
if you have ever heard of change data
capture or cdc that's a good starting
point for understanding change streams
in cloud spanner
change streams keep track of changes
made to data through dml or spanner
mutations that can then be processed by
pipelines to publish in a downstream
system
there are many reasons you might want to
get data changes from one system into
another you might have a data warehouse
and you need real-time information to
improve business decisions
you might want to trigger downstream
application workflows for instance
restocking an item if the inventory
level drops beneath a threshold
you might have a need to keep an audit
trail of changes in a separate system
for compliance purposes
or perhaps you want to keep track of
changes for disaster recovery
whatever the reason the process to set
up a change stream in spanner is
straightforward
first create the change stream in your
database
a change stream is another type of
object in spanner like a table or
secondary index
so you can add modify or delete change
stream objects using ddl
you can create a single change stream
for all tables in a database or you can
create a change stream for specific
tables or even specific columns within
those tables
second you need a destination to receive
the changes
this can be bigquery google cloud
storage google pub sub or any other
system to receive the stream of changes
and finally you set up a pipeline to
process change events from the change
stream and spanner and publish to your
downstream system you can easily build
data flow pipelines to process the
change stream events leveraging spanner
io from the apache beam repository
or you can connect directly to the
spanner api and write your own
processing logic
this might be best to explain with an
example
i currently have an inventory service
for an e-commerce store that is backed
by spanner
i also have bigquery set up to track
inventory behavior over time having this
analytics environment has enabled me to
make good decisions on what items to
keep in stock
currently to get data from spanner into
bigquery i had to set up and maintain
additional pipelines to extract the data
in batches before loading into bigquery
these batches cause some delays that
have caused headaches for my analysts
with change streams i can move to almost
real time streaming of data changes into
bigquery and simplify the logic for
processing
to set up my change stream i go into the
cloud console page for my spanner
instance
then i add my change stream via the ddl
page
the syntax is fairly straightforward
you need a change stream name
change stream names are unique to the
spanner database
next you specify the entities you want
to track in this change stream
you can track the entire database a set
of tables or specific columns for tables
last you specify the retention period
for change stream data
the records that are tracked are stored
for this retention period before
automatically cleaning up
by default the retention period is 24
hours but can range up to 7 days
and you'll pay only for the additional
storage required to keep the change
events longer
now i also have my bigquery environment
set up that is used for inventory
analytics
all i have to do is set up the dataflow
pipeline for bigquery
so i go into dataflow in the cloud
console then create a new pipeline i
provide the pipeline and name
the region i select is us central 1 to
be near my spanner instance
and then i select the cloud spanner to
bigquery template
this template leverages the apache beam
spanner i o connector
here i need to provide some more
information
first is the spanner instance name and
database name
this is the location of the chain stream
object i created earlier
next i need to provide a metadata
instance and database name
this is needed for the spanner io
connector to keep track of the changes
it has processed
the metadata instance and database can
be the same as where the change stream
is located but i'd recommend at least
storing the metadata in its own database
once we've provided the metadata
location then we provide the change
stream name
and finally i specify a bigquery data
set to store the data changes
there are some optional parameters but
this is enough to get started processing
the change streams from when the
pipeline is created
that's it after a few minutes for the
pipeline to get set up i will start
receiving data changes into bigquery
as part of releasing change streams the
spanner team has also released spanner
io to the apache beam repository
spanner io can be used to process data
change events from spanner change
streams
there are also three main data flow
pipeline templates available that
leverage spanner io to quickly get
started processing
spanner change streams
the first is the bigquery template that
i just walked through
this allows you to set up bigquery to
receive changes from spanner in near
real time
there is also a google cloud storage
template
one example of sending data changes to
cloud storage would be to keep an audit
archive of detailed change events on
important data for regulatory purposes
and finally there is a template to
publish data changes to pub sub
this is useful to trigger workflows in
external applications that are listening
on a downstream pub sub related to those
changes
if you need to publish data changes to
another destination or if you need
additional processing of the data
changes then you can create a custom
pipeline that leverages the apache beam
spanner i o connector
it is also possible to connect directly
to the change stream api
to create a customized data pipeline
without using the spanner i o connector
it's possible to have multiple change
streams in the same database and even
multiple change streams tracking the
same tables or columns
here are some things to keep in mind
with multiple change streams
you can have up to 10 change streams per
database and up to three chain streams
can track the same non-key column
you should maintain no more than five
concurrent readers for a change stream
partition
or performance made to grade
change streams is a great new feature in
spanner that enables real-time data
pipelines based on data changes
i have shown how to set up a basic
pipeline to get spanner data changes
into bigquery using the available
dataflow template there are many ways
change streams can be leveraged from
triggering downstream application
workflows using pub sub storing data
within cloud storage to enable data
recovery or for setting up an audit
trail for compliance purposes
let us know in the comments how you're
using change streams and if there are
other templates you'd like us to provide
in the future
[Music]
you